[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online know what you thought of mommy's
performance today pink and her
five-year-old willow enjoyed a
mother-daughter date out at the movies
while Nick and Vanessa Lachey soaked up
the Sun on a family vacation alongside
their kids Camden and Brooklyn I'm very
excited another famous family having fun
The Smiths here's will and Jaden taking
some silly selfies after the 18 year old
chopped his dreadlocks off for his new
film life in a year Khloe Kardashian
shared this sweet snap to Instagram
loving on her man Tristan Thompson the
32 year old opened up about her beau in
the new issue of ES magazine where she
got candid about the idea of marriage
she gushed quote yes I would accept if
he proposed I've never been in this type
of love I just want to live my life and
be happy
meanwhile stranger things star Shannon
purser opened up on Twitter about having
anxiety when it comes to her sexuality
the 19 year old actress wrote quote
getting comfortable with your sexuality
is a process it's going to be okay I
wish I had known that sooner